this is a production of cornell
university
thank you very much neil and bill for
the invitation i'm really uh honored to
come on this fellowship here to
tell you a little bit more maybe how
we are managing the resource the peat
resource in canada and say when i say we
we can talk a little bit about we
because
it involves the canadian sphenum peat
moss association with regroups all the
peat producer of canada and i've been
working in collaboration with them since
1992
exchanging information and all that so
but more specifically today i will talk
about the all we go about to restore uh
industrial peatland
and the main factors that
impedes this recovery
so the plan for today i will talk a
little bit about the restoration context
in north america
which is a different than what's going
on in europe
uh the restoration ecology of peatland
so introducing the our conceptual
framework of research
and the main ibiotic factor in painting
and talking about how we go about to
evaluate success and if
i will check somebody will check on time
and if i have time then um
uh because most i will talk about
sphenum dominated petan or the you know
the sign on peat moss but i can start
with what we're doing uh with fan
research fan restoration research and
the pool also restoration within the
piedmont
so the business of horticultural peat
if we are impacting an ecosystem
environment why should we go on to do
that
if there's alternative
there might be some alternative to using
peat in growing media such as the core
the cocoa fibers
or rock wool or but all of them will
have
you know
its array of problems also in terms of
its use its environmental problem
peat is good just uh
the people that do not know sphyno is
because they have this amazing cell
structure of alternating
lives living cells and dead cells with
lots of pores and and it works a little
bit like a slinky you can compress it
but as soon as you release the pressure
then you have the structure
so it's really good that wicking
the the water and having water into the
substrate and keeping some water there
but also we have with all this for this
aeration and we can get oxygen down to
the root so that's just the basic gets a
good catalina exchange capacity and all
that
i think neil and and
bill could tell you a lot more about
its property but it's just a fantastic
uh
medium to grow plants in and it's not so
easy to all at once get rid of it they
tried that in england
uh they forced the government just
banned the use of pete but they realized
the professional world just could not
go away from it and
just to tell you a little bit about a
little bit more about why it's not so
easy to shift and get rid of all at once
of repeat is we're thinking compose okay
in the last 10 15 years we all agree
compose composting now green residue is
a lot
uh it's more stable and we can get
better growing media out of compost but
the problem in places like in europe or
central europe
is that the green residue are used
uh for for the cent the thermal station
this the to produce energy so they are
not easily available it's not a product
that is it's too
costly for the professional grower to
use so then
for them they rely on peat and then if
you go for the choir the core the coming
from the cocoa fibers then again there's
other issue when you look at the overall
life cycle analysis where it comes from
and that permanently the transport is
kind of polluting on these old boats
also
in the ocean with this diesel bowl that
are not so up-to-date so
i think we have to all this product i'm
not saying this is yet the best thing to
use but i think now we have to start to
look more the overall picture the social
impact
the traveling and the the the whole life
cycle analysis of the different products
so
when you harvest the peatland
usually set
ditches every 30 meters this is the main
ditches
and you have this vacuum drowned
tractor
that will
harvest the peat so you hire the pea
surface let it dry in the sun two three
days later you go with a big vacuum pick
it up two three
four millimeters at a time drop it there
then you charge it onto trucks that
takes to the plant so
some large scale operation will look
like this
and yeah just one we don't see trees we
don't see seeds nothing is left and
nothing we know that 30 centimeter below
the soil the peatland there's no seed
bank left okay so it's not there
so the first question we asked what is
the
ecological distance to restore this how
do we fix this gap between what you saw
and what a natural peatland can look
like you know it's that's quite a step
that's what we uh
and
i just say what i'm showing today comes
from you know it's been developed with
lots of people it's not all at once it
looks easy but we worked 20 years in our
partnership with the canadian peat
industry
and this is like
close to 22 partner and the way it works
in canada is that the federal government
the research council they say that if
the industry industry is interested
when they put one dollar we put one
dollar for financing the research so
more or less it's the way it lies it
goes and then through these
20 years there was numerous you know
post-doc phd student and master's
students and research fields assistant
and volunteer even i know some students
from
uh cornell came and worked up uh with us
so
um just to say that i'm grateful for all
the work with these students
so the way we work is
first
we start by comparing the reference
ecosystem so which is the notion of
these a set of natural ecosystem in our
region to what has been degraded and we
look at the degraded ecosystem
to see
what is this ecological distance we have
to feel
what should we
do
and then we do that by comparing from my
part because i'm the plant ecologist but
we are business disciplinary team
there's people that do the same thing
with hydrology
or the microbiology the microbes
population but for me i will more focus
today on on my specialty within the team
which is the plant ecology so i compare
the plant structure the composition how
i differ and the different functions how
it differs
and if you take
meal plate as i've shown you the
distance is much better greater than
when we used to block cut pain
like this is what we used to do
traditionally or the way that now
that some people are still doing it but
on a smaller scale
but the big distance is really more what
my research has been focused mostly on
this but we are doing research in that
area that i will not talk about today
so if we do no management in a
sphenum-dominated peatland
we uh inventory
395
abandoned peat field all across
canada
mostly than the eastern part this is
where the industry mostly is and i just
want to draw your attention that if you
have natural peatland
and compared to the vacuum and here our
ecosystem were it's close to 600
plots you know that we took in natural
peatland throughout the the
the eastern part of canada
look in general in peter and you will
find about 70 75
of sphenom where there's barely any and
what you found there is mostly what you
found in the ditches but not so much in
the peat field
okay the same thing with the irrigation
shrubs you know there's a lot more
pressure of natural feed than
in a degraded system and look at the
bare peat you know we have no bear peak
in natural system and this is
just you know
and then we did the same thing with fan
which in a different system okay bug are
dominated by sphyno mussels finn are
dominated by sedges and brown mussels
another type of masses
fan paint is
starting more to go into growing media
but mostly it's being used a lot for
energy
consumption in ireland central europe
and russia below russia and these places
but we look in these different
provinces including here
in michigan the the because as you go
down in the peat profile in the p10 you
get down to the fan layers because the
your piton develops as you know a leg
button and will start to accumulate with
organic material
then sedges typha plants like that will
start to fill it up and that's where you
get your
fan peat where you are still have inputs
from
the
different streams around or from the
mineral ground flowing through it and
then with time you have
accumulation of the organic matter
then slowly you get rid of the influence
of the mineral the mineral trophy or
from the
inputs from the runoff of the different
streams and you'll get only the
influence that the system will be fed
only by rain water and then ph will go
down sphenum gets in the system sphenol
gets the ph kicks in the ph to go okay
and then looking now comparing
22
uh peat extracted fan compared to
pretend on disturb then we found that
here we there was two techniques on time
of getting the peat out sometimes it was
drained not drained but you see the
sedges the carrot species in natural
pita on much higher abundance where they
are barely present in these abundant
system and the sphenom the richer cyanum
species so i know centralia and all that
not so much that you found they're
closely not there so
you know we see that even though system
has been abandoned for a long time
up to 40 years they are not there
second step now we have to work to
define goals if you want to do
restoration you have to define your goal
if you don't know your goals
it's hard to evaluate your success you
don't know where you're going
but goals can not only cannot be done
only by scientists or ecologists minded
you have to take care of what's going on
around you in your
society in your community
but ecologically
we know that the restore ecosystem
will not be like
the original one
so you have to define your goals that
will be that but usually nobody will put
we're just going to restore the original
ecosystem that was there before we
cannot do that we don't have the same
climatic history it will not be the same
evolution we're on the on under
different climate now so definitely the
restoration system the restaurant system
will be there
sometime
in the time so we have this time scale
here
goal defining goal is really different
differs from your community i've been
involved with uh people working in
alaska and the main concert in alaska if
we're going to work with the peatland
that was complete then what
is all the fastest way we can again
stabilize the peat so we won't get all
the pits to go in the streams and clog
the rivers that are so important for the
salmon industry it's the fishing
industry so
i can tell you if you talk with anybody
in alaska the first thing they will be
thinking is hey peach should be
stabilized as soon as possible after we
finish using the peat for
whatever reason
in canada with the peat industry the
articulate peat industry we did several
workshops and all that and after
a
different
um
discussion the general long-term goal we
decided was to restore the most unique
characteristic that defines piton
ecosystem which is its capacity to
accumulate p through time so to
sequester carbon through time
p trans are the most efficient ecosystem
we have on this planet
per you know square meter or per volume
that can sequester
carbon on a long time
you know after that you'll have the coal
formation
but really
the peak is more efficient than you can
have forest because forests you plant
trees but 200 years down the line the
trees dies again and the carbon is put
back into the
every circulation so that's the general
long-term goal long-term goal that
we put together because in north america
in muslim canada we were in a wetland
system we use a wetland system
if we leave it you usually birch will
invade it will turn into a birch
woodland or pine woodland and we have
plenty of woodlands in canada but in
southern even though we have a lot of
peatlands in canada there's plenty of it
we don't have so many in the south
nearby the urban area you know there's a
lot of pressure on the wetlands so
that's where
we decided to work and this was
influenced by the kenyan usa uh policy
of no net loss of wetland and the usa
wetland hacks you know overall and and
the reason it was influenced by that is
because the clients are mostly americans
85 85 percent of the peat is sold in the
states
and so we we
we are taking into account some of the
concerns that the clients restoration
limits
like i told you impossible to restore
the original ecosystem by prior to peat
extracting activities this is not you
know uh one of the goal
and peat is not a renewable resources
within human lifetime but the potential
needs here when i say you always have to
define this when you start talking about
this and here i'm talking i'm just
defining the spatial area as being what
is owned and seen by a pet company
okay if we compare it to the potential
of all of our all above all across
canada yeah you could say pete is
renewable because it's
tiny what we are extracting compared to
the amount of people we have in canada
but a lot of it is on the permafrost and
not available
okay so
the shortened goal is really to favor
the establishment of spinal muscles
or now mostly doing a lot of research on
the ground muscles and surgeons
depending on the military fee and mostly
it is well known all these
spinal muscles are really ecosystem
engineer they are the key species in the
northern hemisphere to get
peatland in the uh in the system
so there's a
third step that i'm skipping which is
all the planification which is really
important to succeed in restoration
but as ecologists we work a lot on
defining
what are the constraints
to
why is it that our system is not going
along that way naturally and how can we
ameliorate this constraint they can be
environmental
and that's mostly all my earlier
research was been done in in the spheno
type of peatland
there can be a problem of dispersion
and
this i'm not doing much research on this
because we did it in the beginning
things do come in the plants the the
spores
and all that but the condition is so
harsh nothing established so we know we
have to
just bring the plant material here so
you won't hear a lot much about research
about that and this is the interspecific
interaction plant plant interaction they
do come in for the fans but i will not
discuss this much today
so
and the process of ecostem restoration
then we will also do some monitoring to
adapt
okay so if we do no management things
that happen we know that the peat
oxidation will continue at a rate of 5.7
millimeter per year so it's a net carbon
emission you have an ecosystem you
wonder you use a resource and if you
abandon the system it goes on you see
here trees that establish they get
uprooted through time and there's uh dr
maria strak she's from university of
calgary and she's really our carbon
flock specialist working on all these
questions within our group if we do no
management
all the water chemistry is unstable
because it's coupled with we get a
greater water table fluctuation also so
we have a problem with nutrient and in
the chemistry and this we work with uh
jonathan price is a pico necrologist
from universal waterloo and myself i do
work on the chemistry
peak
erosion the water will impede
you know the vegetation return so
we have to take care of that and also
the wind
you know will impede the vegetation
return so this is all this this
different aspects
and if we do
in some cases do nothing we'll have the
woodland would replace
on this final mosses so either here you
see the birches or the pinewood lens
and we get severe constraint by uh
defrost heating i'll come back on this
and if we don't restore here this is a
site i visited
in colorado
somehow in colorado 100 to 120 years ago
they the the silver mine they had to use
pete in the process
and these are two colleagues david
cooper from us of colorado's from the
boulder and rob chambers from michigan
tech university
and we do a lot of exchange because they
do they've been working on fan
restoration mostly
and now they're starting to adapt some
of our techniques
this is the thromos that you will see
later but some other things makes them
these sites you know this is a site
abandoned
between 100 and 120 years and with all
the harsh conditions plants do not come
back on the peat not so well easy
and then
if you have a fan then you get this kind
of literal species that you have to
compete with
okay so
just to give you an example you won't go
into that but just to say that we did a
lot of work to understand if we were
introduced plans
what can we do to help mostly the
sphenum establishment all our research
has been key to that and this is the
website where we have all our
publications if you're going to put it's
all in english website you can have
access to all the publication
of this uh and what i wanted to say that
what is in yellow are the three
necessary steps
that needs to be done if you don't omit
one of these steps you won't succeed to
restore people you need to reintroduce
your plant material
you need to protect it after that mulch
it because the muscles have no roots
okay no way of controlling the
loss of water
and
still even if you do those two things
you need to block the former drainage
system you need to re-wet the cycle
the combination of these three actions
will lead you usually to successful
one example of one of these let's say a
line of work
is uh the sudden the abiotic factor
the peat surface when we abandon them
can get very hot can be really hot up to
50 degrees c
um
at first we were wondering is it because
there's some toxicity that the plant
don't come back there's no toxicity and
actually even nitrogen is is there
because you have oxidation but no plants
is taking it up so you have even more
nitrogen than the natural glucose so
that should not be but then you have
this biological cross
algae or lichen sometimes and this
really impedes the muscles to have
access to the water underneath so
there's a breakage in the capillary
action
so
we wanted to know at the same time okay
so i have my colleagues looking at the
climate microclimate and what's going on
in ideology and myself i go in the lab
and then i wanted to know what kills the
mosses when are they dead really you
know if i'm reintroduced them
what adverse condition can they
sustain so either with temperature or
here just submitted them to some known
relative humidity created by so like
they were suspended in the air and then
looking back for 10 weeks you know if
they would start to regrow again what if
they were dead or not
so um
that's the way and and with this
i found out that you know
if your relative humidity is low just
for a few hours every everything is is
dead and this is
testing like six different species and
different treatments but
when we get somewhere around 50 percent
you know
i know my plants can stay alive for a
good six days
and that's what you have to find what
and then you know relative humidity will
always go up in the night a little bit
and but it's the hot days we wanted to
know what care so we know it's even
though you put your plants there and a
lot of that if you get that
drought period you will lose all your
material
and then
again working in collaboration with
people working on microclimates then we
look at what does the addition of the
stromals compare when you are there pete
and really we ameliorated a lot
our
interface condition between the peat and
the atmosphere
and then we started to try different
type of mulching we did up to 17
different type
what would be the best and it just
happened that the thrombos which is the
cheapest
and decomposed quickly when you get all
this final that that was the one that
worked really nicely
um
re-wetting
so
we did some uh
try some re-wetting when we just
uh see this is a drain piston here where
the
water table fluctuation this is the
water table would be between
80 centimeter below the surface and and
40 and growing to as august gets drier
you know we go down to one meter a
natural piton will also do the same
thing
but you know not go so much
lower than 40 centimeter and we know
in general we have to keep
around that figure to to have the plants
alive
and then we knew that if we block the
ditches
here to try to re-wet is it sufficient
well it is good in the spring but when
again you arrive in the drought period
in july august we still have a gap that
is too much to keep the plants alive
so
there's action that needs to be there so
to see if you only block the ditches you
don't get your water table back to where
you want it and and this is where the
mulch will do the job a combination of
re-wetting and mulching
so
we started to do bonds embankment we did
more
more than just blocking the ditches can
we redistribute the water through the
system through the whole episode
so if you look this is a
a site that we restore in new brunswick
and there was almost a meter and a half
two meters different between this pool
here in the peatland and this road
access
and again your scale this is 30 meters
here
so you see these bonding we did to keep
the water
uh to redispute it and see
what he would do and we compare then we
put these
water wells all across it and into the
unrestored part just to see where we
work hard at into our restoration
now follow me because it's a bit it's
easy but it's just we inverted the uh
the legend if we just look at the water
table on the top this is the red is the
restore the natural peatland harvested
pizza
so
and again this is minus i mean 20
centimeter below the paint surface 80
centimeter
and and you see how
uh the restore is actually wetter even
in the natural nearby peatland
so which we are really good
in the system
but what is more important for the plant
it's not so much a water table and if
there's a group should know that it's
more you than
our psychologist in general is the
tension the water tension
and and we know that
the muscle this kind of muscles you need
to keep it above
uh minus 100 millibar in order that the
cell can have access to the water from
the peat
and
here this is the reverse
from there this is the restore the green
line
and this is the untreated so they own
restore
but just look we know now this is
this is really not good for the
for for the system so if we do a
combination of blocking and
redistributing the water
we keep the spinal that we just
reintroduced
within above that
minus 100 millibars so this is this
combination of
of these two action that we know works
best for the
now throughout this process
we do some short-term monitoring and
some longer term
because
it's a developing process because we're
doing some small trials to solve a
problem but we're doing some large-scale
one
and and trying to see and how to adapt
so through this loop of monitoring and
this is this is the important
important part if ever any of you get
involved in a
restoration ecology
project in an ecological reservation
project
there's need to be a component three and
five years down the line at least
to go back and see if you've you know
what's been done this has been a
production of cornell university on the
web at cornell.edu